royal fashion fans get excited princess
diana's 1981 wedding gown is set to go
on display
at kensington palace in london this
summer
the new exhibit titled royal style in
the making was announced by the historic
royal palaces via twitter
and is set to examine the relationship
between fashion designer and
royal client the gown which was designed
by elizabeth and david emmanuel
was worn by diana during her 1981
wedding to prince charles
with diana she she chose us because she
was used to the designs that we did she
liked them
felt comfortable e.t spoke with
elizabeth emanuel back in 2018
ahead of the royal wedding of meghan
markle and prince harry
and she reflected on designing diana's
iconic gown
and how not all things went according to
plan that day
well we'd done a practice run of putting
diana into the coach
wearing a calico 12 but we didn't really
take into account the train
because that was 25 foot of it so when
she actually did get into the coach and
her father who's quite a large man was
sitting next to her
and there was 25 foot of train you can
imagine it was a bit of a crush
so when she came out the coach it was
you know a bit of a shot for us to see
the creases
although we had anticipated a bit the
dress is now owned by diana's sons
prince william and prince harry
who have loaned it to the hrp for the
exhibit
the brothers are also planning to unveil
a statue of their mother at kensington
palace this summer
in honor of what would have been her
60th birthday
on july 1st prince harry publicly
reunited with prince william to attend
their grandfather
prince philip's funeral earlier this
month a sign that the recently icy
relationship between the brothers
was thawing this was just an icebreaker
anyone thinking that everything has been
resolved
awake i think is sadly you know
misguided royal expert katie nichols
spoke to et about the possibility of
prince william and prince harry
putting their royal rift aside for their
mother's statue unveiling
later this year things were not going to
be resolved in
in one or two family meetings so while
this has been
an important step i think there's still
quite a way to go
the idea that harry's suddenly going to
come around to william's way of thinking
and vice versa
i think is is a way off i think there do
need to be
more conversations there's clearly still
a lot of hurt
a lot of resentment and a degree of
mistrust
i think on both parts so it's early days
but i think the hope is that
come july when we are hoping to see the
brothers stand
once again shoulder by shoulder to
unveil the statue in memory of their
mother
that the relationship will be stronger
and in a better place
you